DAN ATKINS: All right.
Hi, everybody.
Thank you for joining us today
for a panel we're calling
The Reality of Virtual Reality.
We like the title.
It sounds dramatic.
My name is Dan Atkins.
I'm a publishing
producer here at Google,
focused on Daydream, which
for us is a combination
of both our AR and VR efforts.
But today we're going
to be talking about VR.
And VR, as you guys know, is
still very much an emergent
medium.
It's one where we're
continuing to learn
from every product
that comes out.
And more importantly,
we're still in this phase
where app developers can still
learn a tremendous amount
from game developers,
and vise versa.
So we're lucky enough today
to be joined by two people who
really run the spectrum of VR
entertainment in the industry
right now and have been
pretty prolific in doing so,
both having shipped
multiple titles
across multiple platforms.
So Nic, Jonathan, thank you
guys so much for being with us.
JONATHAN FLESHER: Thank
you for having us.
DAN ATKINS: Yeah, absolutely.
I'm hoping that
we can start just
by hearing a little bit
about who you guys are
and what brought you to VR, and
a little bit about the products
you've been working on.
So Nic, maybe we
can start with you.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Sure.
My name is Nic Vasconcellos.
I am one of the founders
of Turbo Button.
We are a small
indie studio in LA.
We are three people strong
and just recently released
this game, "Along Together"
on Google Daydream.
And the game is--
you play as a kid's
imaginary friend,
going on these adventures.
And you have the power to
move things in the environment
and help this kid
find their lost dog.
So we've been going for
a couple of years now.
We started in the
beginning of 2015.
Started by doing a
couple of Gear VR games,
and then this is our latest.
DAN ATKINS: Awesome.
And Jonathan.
Do you want to do the same?
JONATHAN FLESHER:
I'm Jonathan Flesher.
I work at a company
called Baobab Studios.
It was founded by
Maureen Fan, who
used to run the "Farmville"
franchises at Zinga.
And Eric Darnell, who
was the writer/director
of the "Madagascar" films
when he was at Dreamworks.
And Larry Cutler,
who is our CTO, who
was the head of global
character animation
technology at Dreamworks.
And so we've really
come together
as bringing traditional
cinematic animation
and video game talent
to create something
new for virtual reality.
And you'll see on the screen,
we have three pieces today.
The first one, "Invasion!"
most recently won an Emmy award.
We're very flattered
to have that happen.
And it's been a top performing
app across all the platforms.
"Asteroids!" will be
released this holiday season
on Daydream.
And "Rainbow Crow" will be
coming out sometime next year.
DAN ATKINS: Awesome.
And I think we have a
clip to watch on that one.
JONATHAN FLESHER:
On "Asteroids!"
DAN ATKINS: On "Asteroids!"
JONATHAN FLESHER: Yes.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- [INAUDIBLE].
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Cool.
DAN ATKINS: I love that clip.
JONATHAN FLESHER: Thank you.
DAN ATKINS: Very cool.
So I'm wondering if we
can start a little bit--
I want to take us through the
life cycle of a product, here.
And so I was wondering
if we can start
with a little bit about the
concept phase for you guys,
particularly ideation.
How do you define a razor,
what makes a good idea for VR
versus a bad idea?
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Sure.
For us, so Turbo Button,
we only do VR games.
That is our focus,
is the gaming side.
So a lot of times, there's two
ways that we'll start ideas.
One is with interaction,
which is probably the biggest
way that we start things.
It's like does this thing
just feel good in VR?
Very often mechanics driven.
And it doesn't even--
I think because everything is so
early on, like you were saying,
it might not be the
most mind-blowing thing,
but even just the smallest
interaction design
that can just feel really
good feels like 10 times
better because it's in VR.
And so it's just really finding
those core little moments
that feel really nice and
then building around those.
And then sometimes we also
come from the other direction.
I'd be curious to know how
you guys think about it.
Because it's just thematic.
It's like, oh, I want to
be in this world, or just
a little moment of whether
it's a character looking at you
or something like
that, that can be
the hook, the hook moment
that you build everything else
around.
So yeah.
JONATHAN FLESHER: We come at
it very much from a narrative
storytelling perspective.
That's the benefit of having
a guy like Eric Darnell
is he's very prolific
in terms of his ideas
and has written a
number of scripts
that we then start with.
These are the story lines.
And he actually will pitch
them to the office as a whole,
so we have these
brainstorming sessions.
And then he runs
through the story,
and then we get
feedback from a story,
and he takes that
and adjusts it.
And then we go into
interactive sessions,
thinking about wouldn't it
be cool if we could do this.
And so there's already
starting to be this emerging
body of things that happen in VR
that people have attached names
to, like the dollhouse effect.
Do I lean in and
see little people
and peer into their
houses, to I'm in water.
I put my head above
water, I put it below, I
see under the water.
And all those types
of things are super
cool to be watching
created in this new medium
because it's just like
when smartphones came out,
and "Angry Birds" did
the I can actually
get the feel of like a
slingshot on a piece of glass.
So this is that new
thing here, and that's
kind of how we go
through that process.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Yeah.
And I think our razor for what
works or doesn't work often
comes down to comfort.
Very often comfort, at least.
It's like any little
thing that can feel weird
can make you feel ill or
dizzy or something in VR.
It's very easy to do.
And I think, especially in our
earlier days of our company,
we would do a lot
of experimentation
around camera motion.
A couple of our games are
these third person experiences
like "Along Together"
where the camera's moving
through the environment,
and that can very easily
make people feel uncomfortable.
To develop those systems
to make them comfortable,
we literally will
be just like laying
on a sofa for about an hour,
because we've tried something,
and it's like, oh, god.
JONATHAN FLESHER:
You need the guys
without the depth
perception at the office who
don't get nauseous.
NIC VASCONCELLOS:
Exactly, exactly.
We're not those
guys, none of us.
JONATHAN FLESHER: And I'd say to
follow up on that, in addition
to the comfort level, the things
that we're really focused on
is that interactivity
that you're layering in
doesn't really detract
from the narrative.
That's of critical
importance to us
as storytellers is that
the interactivity enhances
the story as opposed to becomes
the focus of the experience.
DAN ATKINS: So I
mentioned prototyping
plays a significant role
in this as well, right?
You guys are trying
different things in software
as you're going and figuring
out what makes sense.
What's the razor for you guys
between talking about an idea
and being convinced that
it's worth building?
NIC VASCONCELLOS:
You can start off.
[LAUGHTER]
JONATHAN FLESHER: That's
a really tough question.
Because right now, VR
is a brand new media.
If you come from the film,
television perspective,
that's a very, very
well-known vocabulary.
So if you go to film school
anywhere in the world,
they're going to talk about hard
cuts, soft cuts, pans, zooms,
all these types of things that
is the language of storytelling
in film and television.
And once you get to VR, it's
all thrown out the window.
You're no longer on a set.
You no longer have this window
that you're looking through.
You are now in the
experience, and there's stuff
that can happen all around.
So a lot of that
stuff is all new.
So it's really
hard to say there's
a well-defined process for
determining whether it works
or it doesn't, because
it's all brand new.
And so that's part
of the excitement,
but also the challenge of
working in this medium.
DAN ATKINS: Totally.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Getting
it in people's hands
as quickly as possible has
really been our biggest thing.
And it's hard.
I mean, you are dealing with
so many different problems
and things you're trying to
overcome during development,
and you don't often have
time to throw it at people.
But the sooner you can get
it into somebody's hands
and really find out what's
working and what's not.
Everybody always wants to
develop their best practices
for everything,
but I think we're
not quite there yet for VR.
There like there are certain
things here and there that we
have learned ourselves or
heard from other developers
or whatever that we can try
to avoid or specifically do
because it makes things better.
But I think those rules
are not hard and fast.
They don't work in
every situation.
Something that actually
feels good in one situation
might feel terrible in another.
And so it's really just
about how other people react.
And it's the same.
No matter what you're
developing, whether it's VR
or not, you are
looking at this thing
that you're creating
for so many hours
that it's hard to have any
kind of perspective on it
until you see somebody
else react to it.
JONATHAN FLESHER: And I would
say there's a lot of stuff
that when you come
out of the film
and television or the video
game industry that actually
is applicable.
So we actually do
do storyboards,
even though those are
obviously 2D versus not
an immersive environment.
There is a pacing and a
way to direct the scene,
even though it's immersive.
And I'd say that the beauty of
what game engines like Unity
are doing right now--
they call it the real time
revolution-- is the
traditional animation process
was animating in Maya and
then going into RenderMan,
and you'd have to wait
forever for this stuff
to be rendered out, and
then you'd look at it
and go, oh, that's not right.
And then you go back,
and you have to redo it.
Whereas our developers
can sit, just like
is normal in the video game
business, where you'd be like,
what?
It's not normal?
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Yeah, exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
JONATHAN FLESHER: They'd
put on their headset,
and they'd see it there.
Oh, I need to put
a cup on the table.
Oh, I should have this
character come in from here.
And they can go and make
those changes in real time
and see it right away.
And so that rapid prototyping is
new for the animation industry
but I think very comfortable
for the video game industry.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Yeah.
I think we spend a
lot of time doing
a lot of rapid
prototyping and game jams
and all that kind of stuff, just
to try ideas out really quickly
and throw them out.
And actually, storyboarding
is one of the things
that we had a hard time
with at first, too.
Just figuring out how
to lay out the space,
I remember our artists,
I was like, hey,
we need like a storyboard
for this moment.
Here are the beats.
Figure out what you
want this to look like.
And he's drawing everything
in these tiny squares
and shots and camera angles,
and I'm like, uh, no.
I basically had to go back in
and redraw the frames for him,
but very lightly.
And I was like, you know what?
Feel free to draw outside this.
Think about how this
whole space feels.
And that really
helped at the time,
and now, seeing things
like Google Blocks
and Unity is starting to do some
of their real time VR editing
tools and stuff like that.
Do you guys use any of
that for laying stuff out?
JONATHAN FLESHER: Yeah.
We've used both
Unreal and Unity,
and we're currently building
our current two pieces on Unity,
and so we use their
timeline feature heavily.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Yeah, I bet.
JONATHAN FLESHER: And there's
a lot of really interesting
things that they're
disrupting again
in the traditional
animation industry,
but it's quite
comfortable for games.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: It's crazy.
I really want to get my hands
more on actually editing
scenes in VR.
Because actually, one
of the hardest things
is starting a new level
and really understanding
what the scale of
that place feels
like compared to yourself.
We do a lot of
scaling up and down
of the character to do the
toy box effect like you
were talking about.
So we don't always--
it's very hard to imagine
until you're actually in it
what the scale of
that thing will be.
JONATHAN FLESHER:
Storyboarding, there
are companies out
there developing tools,
and people have tools internally
to do storyboarding in VR,
and that's some of the
rapid prototyping tools
that are being developed and
used out there right now.
Really helps.
DAN ATKINS: So we have these
rapid prototyping tools
that allow us to
visualize things
far more quickly and
experiment far more quickly,
which is clearly a benefit
to animation and games.
As you guys have been going
through this rapid prototyping
phase, and you're
actually moving
from that prototyping phase
into building your products,
what are some of
the biggest mistakes
you've made trying to author
content in this new medium?
Obviously, there is
the sending people
to the couch to be
sick for a while
when things don't go super well.
But what are some others?
JONATHAN FLESHER:
I'd say for us,
it's being heavy-handed
with the users.
It's pretty
interesting, because you
have to prepare for everything
from an experienced VR
user, which there are shockingly
few out there right now,
just given the penetration
of the platform,
to complete newbies.
And so you'll find people who
will jump in the experience,
and they'll just start
staring off into the distance,
or they won't even
move their head.
Move your head.
They're like, whoa!
And you have to
plan for all those,
but I think a core learning
is that people, just
like in every other
media, they don't really
like to be forced
what to do, so you
have to entice them
to do the things
that you want so that they can
experience the story as it was
meant to be told, in our case.
So heavy-handed things like
forcing them into a position,
or doing something,
or not allowing
them to interact with something,
has been less well-received
versus others.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Audio's a
huge thing for that, right?
JONATHAN FLESHER: Yes.
Audio characters.
We often say one of the
things you can do in VR
is think like a magician.
If you want the
audience to look at you,
you look at the audience.
If you want them to
look at something else,
you look at that.
That happens.
And if you have big,
expressive characters,
that's fairly easy to achieve.
And then obviously, audio cues.
It's a little challenging
with the audio
because not everything works
that well in spatialized audio.
Not everybody has
high-tech headsets.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Especially if
you're on mobile or something,
right?
JONATHAN FLESHER: Uh-huh.
So you've got to be
able to span that gap.
And I think just like
in games, it often
helps to think of the
lowest common denominator
and build up from there.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Yeah.
I think actually, maybe--
you would probably
hate me for this.
But one of the things that we
have traditionally had problems
with in the past is actually our
character interaction moments.
We've definitely spent a lot of
time prototyping interactions
and gameplay mechanics.
And we still very much value
characters and narrative
and all that kind
of stuff, but we do
come from a gaming background.
And so we definitely have had
times in some of our products
where we don't prototype our
character interactions early
enough.
And some of them end up working,
and it's great, and yeah.
But we've definitely
had moments where
we build out this whole
character interaction.
In my head, I'm like,
this is going to be great.
It's going to be awesome.
And then it totally flops.
And now you're
like, well dang, I
have to restructure
my whole story.
That was a pivotal moment.
JONATHAN FLESHER:
Welcome to our world.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
JONATHAN FLESHER: And
the piece that we're just
releasing this holiday
is you actually follow
the two aliens that were in the
first piece, "Invasion!", who
came down and invaded
Earth, and were repelled
by a cute little bunny, Chloe.
You follow them to their
ship in outer space.
And we found when we first
put people out there--
you play, actually, a
helper robot on the ship.
And we gave you robotic hands.
And people just start
running around the ship,
jamming their hands
into various places,
thinking they were R2-D2, and
they were going to take over
control of the ship,
there was going
to be some Easter egg somewhere,
and completely missing
the narrative.
Or taking the ball that you
could play fetch with a dog
and like hitting things,
trying to beat the characters.
It's a very, very interesting
thing to run through.
DAN ATKINS: Yeah,
you give somebody
a ball to play fetch
with a dog, and then they
go try to murder
everything with the ball.
One of the things
that strikes me
as you guys are
talking about this
is how some of the most profound
moments in your products,
at least for me, have been
some of the most simple
in some ways.
Like "Invasion!" is always one
of the first VR experiences
I show somebody,
and it's largely
because you have that moment
where Chloe, the bunny,
comes running right up
to you and slides right
into your body.
And you really have this
moment of eye contact,
which is incredibly powerful.
And it's the first
medium I can think
of where you have eye contact.
And then similarly,
with "Along Together,"
the first real interaction
you have in the game
is just waving to
another character,
and how endearing that is
and how much it connects you
to those characters.
Have you guys noticed
a theme of simplicity
in these interactions
that feels important?
Are you noticing that
users are growing
into more complex interactions
as they continue to progress
through more VR content?
NIC VASCONCELLOS:
I think there's
something about
simple interactions
that like immediately
connect with people.
It doesn't matter--
I don't think anybody is
sitting there going, oh, man.
I'm like bored of waving.
Actually, it might
get to that point,
now that I think about it.
If we have too many moments
of you wave to this character,
it's like, OK.
Yeah.
I've done this in VR
before, that's fine.
But I think so far it's been
not so much about just trying
to be like, oh, this is a simple
interaction that would be cool.
It's just what
sells that moment.
And we're not really
necessarily worrying
about how complex it should be.
I mean, especially for the
very beginning of a sequence.
A character looks at you.
You wave at them.
Really pulling somebody
into that experience.
You have to do something
that is minimally--
or it's easy to understand
and as impactful as possible.
I feel like I'm talking
in circles a little bit,
but I think that
is really key to--
especially as we are getting
mostly new users into VR,
we don't really make
games assuming that people
have played VR before.
We're still assuming this
might be the first time
somebody is ever
picking this up,
so how do we make it as easy
to get into as possible?
DAN ATKINS: Absolutely.
JONATHAN FLESHER: I don't
think it's necessarily
a simplistic thing.
The kind of magic of
Chloe coming up to you
and bouncing around, it's
amazing to watch people.
You'll see people start
hopping around on the floor,
trying to jump back and forth.
And they're like, oh my god.
The AI behind that is amazing.
She's reacting to me
and playing with me.
I'm like, no.
That's actually just a
simple hop back and forth.
There was eye tracking in
there, which helped a lot.
But the key piece being
that it's more that it feels
like real life.
And to dig deeper
on that, it is not
that it's necessarily
photorealistic,
because you are actually a
bunny, and that's a bunny,
and it's clearly not real life.
But it's that it feels
natural in terms of the way
that you actually interact
in your day-to-day life.
And that's what
you're striving for.
And that could be a
simplistic interaction.
It could be complex.
Obviously, we're going
to probably stumble
across the more simplistic
ones, because they're
going to be easier for us
to figure out right now.
But as the medium grows
and gets better over time,
those will obviously
become more complex.
But it's that key of
replicating the feel of life.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Yeah.
And I think thinking about the
interactions by themselves,
they might be very simple.
But I think they can
be emotionally complex.
JONATHAN FLESHER:
That's a great point.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Yeah.
And that is what
really feels good.
DAN ATKINS: Yeah.
That makes total sense.
It's funny you mention that,
because I think the reaction I
see from a lot of
people, you can always
tell when the bunny
is about to hit,
because they go [SOUND OF ALARM]
you have that moment.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Actually,
that's kind of fun too,
intentionally doing things that
are slightly uncomfortable.
Not in a physical way, but
just in a way that will make
you go, oh.
It really wakes you
up and gets you going.
That's really fun to play with.
DAN ATKINS: Very cool.
So you both have, at
this point, shipped
multiple products on
Daydream, on Rift,
on all sorts of platforms.
What have you learned
from those releases
that you think you'll apply
to your next products?
What are the biggest
takeaways you've
gotten from these experiences?
JONATHAN FLESHER: I don't
know if I have takeaways.
Right now, it's a
very challenging time
as a developer.
Because if I'm in
the West-- forget
China right now--
but in the West,
there's arguably six
platforms to port to.
And if you're talking about
a video company that's
on consoles or
mobile devices, it's
Sony and Microsoft
or Apple and Google.
It's a much more
limited universe.
And so that's challenging.
I hope that goes away
and narrows down soon.
But the thing that we're
super excited about
is actually taking
the best of Daydream,
which is the portability,
the anywhere,
and expanding that power into
these standalone headsets.
You guys are
launching one shortly.
And being able to bring
more and more rendering
power into those
standalone headsets,
inside out tracking
with Tango, that
solves a whole host of
consumer adoption problems.
Like, it's a pain in the
butt to put boxes up there
and run through that stuff.
So you guys are really
pushing into the area that we
want to go, which is
we think it's mobile.
We think it has
inside out tracking,
has AR pieces to
be layered into it,
and that's the stuff that we're
waiting for and excited about.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: I think for
us, the biggest thing that we
want to continue doing is
character interaction, which
you guys love too, right?
It's fun.
You automatically get a lot
of personality out of it.
You get a more connected feeling
with that world that you're in.
And we've done that, and
every one of our games
so far has been
character-driven.
And it's hard to do in terms
of costs and stuff like that.
I think a lot of
people might shy away
from some of that
sometimes, or just--
I don't know.
I mean, obviously there are
a million different types
of games, and everybody should
play all those different kinds,
but we like to focus on those
character moments and stuff.
And we're only three
people, but our first--
it's me and my business partner,
and our first and only hire
so far has been a full-time
animator, which I think
a lot of people are like why?
JONATHAN FLESHER: No,
that's really smart.
DAN ATKINS: Makes total sense.
JONATHAN FLESHER: Because
I've got to tell you,
characters are core to
what we do as storytellers.
And the simple
idea is that if you
don't care about the
characters, you don't really
care about the story.
And if you're developing
story-driven games,
I think you fundamentally have
to start in that same place,
is that the characters are
critical to that development
of that story.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: I think
I found too-- or at least
this is the feeling
that I get when
I play character-driven
stuff, is
that having other characters
around very quickly
helps ground me in that world
and make me feel like I'm
a part of that story as well.
JONATHAN FLESHER: And again,
you don't have to be human.
You don't have to be--
it doesn't have to
be photorealistic.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: Right.
Not at all.
JONATHAN FLESHER:
I think for us,
the way we like to describe
that, that framework,
because when I was in
video games, I used to say,
video games were just
interactive animation.
And animation was just a
non-interactive video game.
And I've since learned
that I'm not that smart,
and the world's far
more complex than that.
The way we talk
about it at Baobab
is we want the empathy
of the film, the agency
of video games, because you
have that interactive medium,
and the motivations
of real life.
And that comes together,
when you get it right,
in a magical way.
That's our goal of our company.
DAN ATKINS: Absolutely.
So we're running a
little low on time.
Any advice you have for
folks who are thinking
about starting up on Daydream?
Ways to get started, good tools
of the trade, good tricks.
NIC VASCONCELLOS: I think from
the design side of it at least,
we had--
just understanding the
capabilities of the controller
is super important.
I think early on in development
of "Along Together," we
were trying to do a lot of
stuff with the gyroscope
and the accelerometer, and it
had all these features that we
were trying to do a
bunch of stuff with.
I'm not saying this
is always the case,
but for us, really
scaling back and saying,
OK, what is the
simplest way for people
to interact with this controller
and interact with the world?
Kind of like you
were saying earlier,
really figuring out the
simple interactions that
have a big impact.
And we felt like doing too much
with the controller in general,
even though there are all these
things you can do with it,
really increased the
learning curve quite a lot.
So I think really getting
your controls streamlined,
if you're doing a game, or even
just anything with interaction,
I think that's a big place
to start for Daydream.
DAN ATKINS: Awesome.
JONATHAN FLESHER: Yeah,
I'd say, obviously,
Unity makes it a
much easier prospect
to get into mobile devices.
Obviously, you should be
working in a game engine.
I do think that your
point around controllers
is really well said.
There was an interesting stat
that Oculus released last week
at Oculus Connect
around the pieces that
had effective use of the
controller, which theirs
is a 3-DOF controller
as well, dramatically
increased engagement and
length of viewer time.
So I'd say definitely wrap
in a controller [? stream. ?]
And I'd say, finally, don't
try to do too much too fast.
Bite-sized experiments.
See how it goes and learn.
That's probably the fastest
way to get something good out
there.
DAN ATKINS: Awesome.
Well, I want to thank you
both for being here today.
I'm really looking forward to
seeing what you guys do next,
in terms of your next
products, and thank you
for giving us a quick education
on VR and VR storytelling.